the movie begins with a narration
explaining the existence of multiple
universes forming a Multiverse along
with the availability of technology for
inter Universe travel however stringent
restrictions and policing govern such
travel according to the narrator each
human simultaneously exists in the
present time and the parallel universes
maintaining a delicate balance in the
system but recently a disruptive Force
has emerged with the intention of
destroying this balance in order to
attain ultimate power that is regarded
as the one yeah in the next scene we are
shown a prisoner named Lawless who is
about to be transferred to another
prison a group of armed police force
escort him to the police vehicle but
just before entering the vehicle Lawless
is suddenly shot by someone from an air
vent in immediate retaliation the police
force open fire towards the vent but
they are unable to locate the as salant
not long after a guy who appears exactly
like Lawless shows up at the scene this
guy is Gabrielle Ula who possesses a
supernatural ability he is so fast that
he can even Dodge the bullets this is
just the Matrix with his powers he takes
down all the police officers in no time
and runs away shortly after he is chased
down by the Multiverse Authority or MVA
agents radeker and fch Ula runs towards
a specified location where he uses his
high-tech watch to create a portal and
travel to Another Universe just then fch
arrives at the scene and connects his
device with ulas altering the
destination of the portal following this
he holds Ula at gunpoint demanding that
he surrender when the ladder refuses to
comply roader knocks him using a car and
tries to apprehend him at the same time
a portal appears and they all are
teleported to the MVA headquarters in
the alpha Universe once there the other
MVA agents restrain Ula and take him
away while the two agents are provided
with the necessary Medical Aid in the
aftermath of this event Ula is taken to
the universal Court where the
authorities list the crimes he committed
in different universes here it is
revealed that Ula was once an MVA agent
himself but then he changed the path of
his life he started to hunt down the
different variations of himself by
traveling to alternate universes his
motive is to kill all 124 versions of
his other selves and absorb their life
energies so that he can become a
superpowered Godlike being called the
one whoa it turns out that he has
already killed 123 variations of himself
by now with Lawless being the latest one
from the Anubis universe as a
consequence of 123 charges of
first-degree murder and 123 counts of
unauthorized travel to parallel
universes using illegal Quantum
tunneling Ula is now sentenced to life
imprisonment in the stigan penal colony
within the Hades Universe cool names
this movie was written by a big old nerd
afterwards he is brought to a highly
secured room and restrained to a special
chair in order to teleport him to the
Hades Universe before initiating the
portal he is granted an opportunity to
make a final statement during this Ula
says that what he is doing is not a
crime asserting the impossibility of
murdering oneself 123 times he claims
that he just took those wasted energies
and put them into one container his body
this has made him f faster smarter and
stronger he also expresses the belief
that it is their ultimate fate to unite
with their other selves meanwhile a girl
who happens to be ula's lover is also
present in the room she releases a white
mouse from her shoe with a bomb planted
in its body she then detonates it with a
trigger in her ring creating a
distraction and earning enough time for
Ula to release himself after taking down
all the guards in the room he
manipulates the Portal's destination and
teleports himself to the cheris universe
where the last variation of himself
lives the scene then cuts to the cheris
universe where the final known variation
Gabe law serves as a deputy sheriff in
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department he along with his officers
are currently escorting a prisoner to
the police van just like the earlier
scene they are attacked by Ula from the
air vent but this time Gabe manages to
protect the prisoner after a while of
gunfire Ula runs away and easily leaps
off a high wall using his ability Gabe
and the other officers chase him and
much to everyone's surprise Gabe also
manages to climb the wall and get to the
other side there he has taken back to
see his own counterpart before Gabe can
grasp the situation ulash shoots him in
his bulletproof vest as he is about to
finish him off Roder and fch show up in
the nick of time forcing Ula to retreat
after this Gabe returns home where his
wife TK is relieved to see him unharmed
however upon learning that he was shot
she urges him to go to the hospital
hospital for a general checkup Gabe
agrees but he opts to take some time
alone first he then tries to understand
his powers while Ula is simultaneously
practicing some fighting moves in a
Terrace at this point we learn that Gabe
has developed the same strength speed
and mental ability just like Ula but he
didn't have to kill himself 100 times to
get it he just participates in noof fap
November on an annual basis later on TK
takes Gabe to the hospital where his
fellow police officers question him
about the asent however Gabe chooses to
lie claiming that he didn't see the
asent because it was too dark regardless
TK senses that he's withholding
information and talks to him in private
Gabe then discloses that the as salent
was none other than his doppelganger and
that he was inexplicably able to sense
his presence while escorting The
Prisoner out in addition he clarifies
that the doppelganger intent was to kill
him not the prisoner hearing this TK
assumes that he is hallucinating because
of the gunshot so she arranges for him
to undergo an MRI test following this
Gabe takes off all the magnetic
substance from his body and goes for the
MRI in the midst of the test Ula walks
in and holds the doctor at gunpoint but
before he can pull the trigger Roder and
fch intervene demanding that he
surrender Ula deters them from shooting
him citing that if he is killed Gabe
would be left as the one despite this
the agents open fire initiating a
shootout between them all hearing the
commotion Gabe comes out of the scanning
machine and hides behind a wall shortly
after Ula shoots one of the police
officers and fleas the scene TK and the
police officers witness him via CCTV
camera and mistake him for Gabe on the
other hand the real Gabe puts on his
clothes and walks out only to be
confronted by his fellow officers he
tries hard to clear the misunderstanding
but the officers don't believe him as a
result he fights his colleagues and
escapes from the hospital the MVA agents
then decide to deviate from their
initial orders and split up Roder
pursues Ula while fch goes after Gabe
after some time Gabe notices fch tailing
him so he confronts him and questions
the agent about his identity in response
the agent introduces himself and
explains everything about multiple
universes as well as the restricted
portal for inter Universe travel he also
tells him about Ula and his ultimate
goal of killing Gabe to become the one
since our hero is equally powerful fch
requests his help in stopping Ula who is
on the verge of destroying the balance
however Gabe doesn't believe his words
and heads towards home meanwhile Roder
confronts ula in an ambulance and holds
him at gunpoint however the ladder Rams
the vehicle into a crane and starts
fighting the agent an intense brawl
ensues between the two with Ula being
the dominant one after getting beaten up
brutally Roder pulls out a bomb in an
attempt to stop all of this however his
efforts prove futile as Ula easily
disables the bomb and kills him moments
later a patrolling officer arrives at
the scene ordering him to turn himself
in in return Ula demonstrates his
exceptional strength by crushing the
officer with two bikes now that's what I
call an endo on the other hand TK is
escorted back home by a group of police
officers they start checking the entire
house suspecting gab's presence amidst
this TK goes to the bathroom and notices
some blood stains on the soap which
makes her aware that Gabe is here as a
result she sends the officers out of her
room pretending to seek some privacy
following this she begins searching the
room and locates ula in a secret
compartment in the ceiling he poses as
her husband and asks her for a gun as
she goes to retrieve a gun from the
drawer she notices another version of
her husband outside leaving her in shock
unable to figure out who is the real one
she decides to conduct a small test she
asks Ula if he remembers how he proposed
to her at a bookstore when the latter
confirms TK realizes that he is not her
husband and brandishes the gun at him
this is because Gabe had proposed to her
at the clinic not at a bookstore frakin
nerd as soon as his identity gets
exposed Ula attacks and captures her
Gabe arrives at the scene but he can
only watch helplessly as Ula kills his
wife hearing the commotion the police
officers break into the room and Order
Ula to drop the weapon however he uses
his speed to Escape From The Scene Gabe
attempts to pursue him but the officers
once again mistaking him for ulaw start
firing at him just then F shows up and
rescues a guil ridden Gabe from the
police after this tragic event Gabe
finally agrees to join forces with fch
to confront their Mutual adversary fch
then informs Gabe about a portal that
will open in an hour for 3 minutes the
place where they can find Ula he also
shows his self-designed and highly
modified hand portable weapon but Gabe
asserts that he doesn't need any weapons
to defeat Ula with the help of F's
portal tracking device the two arrive at
an industrial plant upon entering Gabe
can sense ula's Pres presence and warns
fch about the same moments later they
encounter him and fch immediately starts
firing towards him however the ladder
easily Dodges the bullets and runs away
a short while later Ula activates the
bomb which he retrieved from Rader
earlier but fortunately Our Heroes
managed to take cover and survive the
huge blast following this Ula confronts
Gabe and the two engage in a physical
Brawl for the first few minutes Ula who
is professional and more experienced
secures dominance over Gabe he even
manages to knock him down at one point
during this Gabe notices a mark of his
wedding ring on his finger which reminds
him of his late wife this fills his
heart with Fury prompting him to get up
and continue fighting with renewed
strength he then eventually manages to
gain the upper hand but only seconds
before the portal opens as a result the
fight remains unfinished and all three
of them are teleported to the MVA
headquarters after this Ula attempts to
deceive Everyone by SW swapping places
with Gabe by this point you think Gabe
would have given himself a haircut or
something initially the MVA officers
fall for the Roose and prepare to
teleport Gabe to the Hades Universe for
punishment however fch notices the
wedding ring mark on gab's finger at the
last moment and uncovers the switch As a
result he alerts the MVA officers about
it who then teleport to reveal Ula to
the Hades Universe in the aftermath the
MVA proceeds to send Gabe back to his
own universe but fch argues that if he
is teleported back he will be arrested
and put into prison for the crimes that
Ula committed due to this fch changes
the destination of the portal and sends
Gabe to a different universe as soon as
he lands there Gabe finds an injured dog
and takes it to a vet clinic where he
meets another version of TK this makes
him very happy and he ends up starting a
new life with TK once again meanwhile
Ula now in the stigan penal colony in
the Hades Universe Still Remains
determined to become the one he engag
ages in a battle against numerous prison
inmates at once the movie ends with the
camera pulling back to reveal an army of
inmates confronting Ula on top of a
pyramid shaped Tower subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching